[Music]
on this Wednesday night damning claims
against a Canadian spy the allegations
he was a double agent smuggling
teenagers for terrorists plus insight
into how intelligence agencies operate
top secret documents discovered inside
former president Trump's home I think
it's going to make it very difficult for
him to blame others the new accusations
he and his team tried to obstruct
Justice first it was quiet quitting now
there's quiet firing it's almost like a
game of chicken the movement gaining
momentum among employers and remembering
the people's princess she was such an
amazing person an icon 25 years since
Diana's tragic and untimely death
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight para Nasser
good evening and thank you for joining
us the Canadian Security intelligence
service is facing tough questions
tonight a new book alleges a thesis
asset was a key part of the smuggling
operation that helped people enter Syria
to join the so-called Islamic State
Muhammad al-rasheed was reportedly
recruited by the intelligence agency
after trying to apply for Asylum at the
Canadian embassy in Jordan Rasheed was
allegedly in charge of the Turkish side
of the Isis smuggling Network and
facilitated the travel of British
citizens for months including shimima
begum and two of her friends begum was
only 15 when she was smuggled into Syria
she went on to marry an Isis fighter our
Ottawa bureau chief Mercedes Stevenson
has been digging into the reports and
she joins us now summer cities what
should Canadians make of these
allegations
well first of all we don't know if
they're true I asked thesis about this
today they said they were going to do
their best to get back to me by the time
we went to air I still don't have a
response from them so we haven't heard
from cesus and we haven't seen the
documents that British media says they
have but we wanted to talk about this
because it raised this important
questions for Canadians about the ethics
around how intelligence agencies work
let's start with talking about who this
person might have been he's not a
Canadian agent who's over there as an
employee of ceases who infiltrated a
network allegedly this sounds according
to senior National Security sources who
I've spoken to like somebody who would
have been an asset for the agency
someone they would have brought in and
recruited who was already involved in
illegal activities that is very common
for intelligence agencies uh
unfortunately a lot of the people who
they work around and pay are people who
are fairly sketchy because they're the
ones who know what's going on if they
actually manage to infiltrate Isis to
that level and get information and how
much they could trust that information
that was probably seen as a win for the
agency and it was interesting to hear
the prime minister's response today when
he was asked about that take a listen
obviously we know we live in a
particularly dangerous world the fight
against terrorism requires our
intelligence services to continue to be
flexible and to be creative in their
approaches but every step of the way
they are bound by strict rules by
principles and values that Canadians
hold dear
their reports Mercedes the three of the
smuggled people were actually underaged
girls who British police are actually
looking for frantically is it surprising
that cesus didn't share information
about them
yeah so it sounds pretty surprising
right you think why wouldn't they just
call the police well I told uh talked to
some people who were very senior in the
National Intelligence architecture here
in Canada and they said it would not at
all be uncommon for ceases to have not
told the police there could be a few
reasons for this number one they were
likely only looking for Canadian
citizens they may not have realized what
they had and even if they did often
intelligence agencies won't talk to the
police even foreign police agencies and
I'm told even the RCMP quite frequently
because they're territorial about their
methods and where they have information
but obviously there's still a lot of
questions about this just how much
Canada was relying on it and how much of
this is actually true pharah Mercedes
Stevenson and Ottawa thank you Mercedes
two members of prime minister Justin
Trudeau's cabinet swapped jobs today
I filming a Tassie do solemnly and
sincerely promise and swear Ontario
Hamilton Ontario MP Philomena Tassie had
been the minister for public services
and procurement she is now the minister
for the southern Ontario Federal
Economic Development agency Markham
Ontario MP Helena jassic will take on
tassie's former duties Tassie requested
the switch so she can spend more time
with her husband who recently suffered
two strokes all 38 cabinet members are
set to head to Vancouver next week for
three days of meetings ahead of the
return of parliament on September 19th
and we are hearing for the first time
from Deputy Prime Minister Christian
Freeland since an incident last week saw
her verbally harassed during a visit in
Grand Prairie Alberta
what happened was wrong
I am conscious that there are a lot of
journalists and politicians across the
country who have a lot less support than
I do
who can face challenging situations and
it is important for all of us to support
them
in the incident captured on video a man
who is now being investigated by the
RCMP approaches Freeland swearing at her
and calling her a traitor as she tries
to enter an elevator criticism on this
has been widespread with politicians
saying it's time to turn down the
temperature and Freeland and others
noting that women of color have faced
the brunt of this kind of abuse
and Elizabeth May has launched her
campaign to reclaim the leadership of
the federal green party May is running
on a joint ticket with Jonathan pedno an
expert on crisis situations now if they
win each promises to appoint the other
as Deputy leader May who is one of two
green MPS in the House of Commons says
the party has been in disarray and
apologized for past mistakes the pair is
among six candidates approved to run in
the leadership campaign the winner is
going to be announced in November
in the U.S the Department of Justice has
released bombshell images from the FBI
search of Donald Trump's Florida mansion
on August 8th the images show highly
classified documents recovered from
Mar-A-Lago now the doj is accusing the
former president's team of moving and
hiding the documents after the initial
search for them Nita Garcia has more
from Washington on the filing and on the
reaction to it
during its August 8th search the FBI
seized 33 boxes with more than 100
classified records stashed in the
ex-president's office according to the
U.S Department of Justice in a new core
filing which includes the doj's most
robust defense yet of the unprecedented
search of Trump's residence
basically said to the Trump people okay
you want to litigate this and tell your
version of events well we have something
to say too and we have pictures this
image of some of the documents seized
shows colored cover sheets indicating
their classified status top secret SCI
which stands for sensitive
compartmentalized information with
bright yellow borders is blazed on the
cover sheets of at least five sets of
papers and secret SCI with rust-colored
borders on another cover sheet there is
a very very rigorous procedure about
when you can look at these documents how
you can look at them you know who looks
at them all of that none of those
security precautions are in place at a
location like Mar-A-Lago yet there they
are sprawled out on a carpet beside a
cardboard box filled with framed
pictures including a Time Magazine cover
the doj also claiming the records were
likely concealed and removed from the
storage room and that efforts were
likely taken to obstruct the
government's investigation it's pretty
obvious to anybody even somebody perhaps
who didn't do their homework or that
this stuff is classified and has to be
treated in a certain way the filing also
States Trump's Representatives falsely
claimed under oath all materials had
been returned but Trump unhappy about
the FBI's photos took to his social
media platform truth social criticizing
the FBI for quote placing the documents
haphazardly on the floor the White House
says it won't comment on this 36-page
brief but just hours before it was 5
late Tuesday President Biden delivered a
passionate speech condemning threats by
Trump supporters against FBI Personnel
there's no place in this country no
place
for an endangering the lives of law
enforcement no place
the justice department is also arguing
that appointing a special Master to
review the materials would harm National
Security and delay the ongoing review
setting the stage for Thursday's hearing
when both sides will argue before a
trump-appointed judge nitu Garcia Global
News Washington
world leaders continue to pay tribute to
the late Mikhail Gorbachev many in the
west are hailing his achievements as the
head of the former Soviet Union but
within Russia reaction to his death has
been largely negative as he's remembered
as the man who allowed the superpower to
collapse Redmond Shannon looks at how
differing perspectives illustrate the
growing gap between Moscow and the West
Berlin's Russian Embassy sits just on
the Eastern side of where the Berlin
Wall used to be the infamous Iron
Curtain brought down under the reign of
Soviet leader Mikhail Gorbachev
I grew up with the wall says this woman
born in West Berlin it was simply great
what he did
German Chancellor Olaf Schultz called
Gorbachev a courageous man who helped
reunite Germany and brought democracy
and freedom albeit somewhat
unintentionally to Eastern Europe
Gorbachev on the Nobel Peace Prize for
ending the Cold War although some of his
perestroika and glasnost reforms have
since been undone
the former head of the Communist World
famously advertised Pizza Hut but thanks
to Vladimir Putin's nationalist war in
Ukraine that Slice of Life Is No More in
Russia Western leaders like Canada's
Brian Mulroney remained friendly with
with him after they left politics and
it'll take time for the value of his
initiatives and his achievements to work
their way through the system and so he's
objectively viewed and I think he will
be considered as an iconic figure and a
great truly great leader
the Western tributes mocked on State tv
in Russia this presenter only said it
would be indecent to speak ill of the
Dead many Russians see him as the man
who allowed the nation to descend into
chaos and lose its status as a
superpower
the Kremlin spokesperson Dmitry peskov
called Gorbachev and naive romantic for
thinking Russia and the West could be
friends Moscow still hasn't decided if
there will be a state funeral
in the west is hero worshiped and in
Russia he is vilified
and yet I think neither
characterizations are entirely true
lithuanians remember how Gorbachev tried
to brutally suppress its push for
Independence he also supported Russia's
2014 invasion of Ukraine when asked
about his legacy in 2011 he said he was
proud of the life he had lived
and let history decide Redmond Shannon
Global News London
a team of un nuclear inspectors have now
crossed over the front line of the war
on route to the zapparisha plant in
russian-held Ukraine
a team of international Technical and
safety experts will be assessing the
safety measures there Europe's largest
nuclear plant has been held by Russian
forces since early March but it is still
being operated by Ukrainian technicians
over the past few weeks the plant has
been hit by multiple artillery attacks
and airstrikes with both sides blaming
each other
and Russia has once again turned off the
Taps on the nordstream one pipeline
stopping the flow of gas to Western
Europe energy Giant Gas prom says the
stoppage is for maintenance and will
last until September 3rd but across
Europe there are fears this outage could
be extended in retaliation for Western
sanctions and the stoppage will impact
Plans by many European countries to
stockpile gas ahead of the winter
new satellite images from NASA show the
impact in southern Pakistan of the
monster monsoon season that's killed
more than 1100 people and impacted 33
million there images that taken last
year show the Indus River the wavy Blue
Line flowing through Sindh Province but
new pictures captured this week reveal
the shocking transformation you can see
the large Blue Area is the Indus River
now roughly 100 kilometers wide as the
flood water has created a giant Inland
Lake overflowing Rich agricultural lands
a critical service for people in Crisis
coming up when a new three-digit hotline
will begin in Canada
Canada's biggest province is moving
further away from pandemic restrictions
Ontario is lifting the isolation rules
for those with covid-19
Ontario's chief medical officer says
Those Who test positive for the virus no
longer have to isolate for five days but
he says they should still stay home for
at least 24 hours or until their
symptoms have improved and keep wearing
masks for 10 days from the day they
started feeling sick Ontario is the
latest Province to scrap such
restrictions following the lead of New
Brunswick
Ontario's police Watchdog says three
officers have been charged in the
shooting death of a one-year-old boy
each face one count of manslaughter and
one count of criminal negligence causing
death a 33 year old man and his
one-year-old son were shot during an
interaction with police in 2020. the
special investigations unit says three
officers opened fire on the man in his
vehicle after he allegedly abducted his
child the boy died at the seam and the
dad died in hospital later
with a toxic drug crisis gripping Canada
there are calls for more action and
renewed urgency on this International
overdose Awareness Day Advocates friends
and families gathered in cities across
Canada to honor the lives of those lost
to overdose educational demonstrations
and conversations happening today the
aim is to bring awareness to the crisis
and to reduce the stigma associated with
substance use this year many provinces
are on track for Grim new records for
overdose deaths
and after a long wait Canada's Telecom
regulator has approved a new three-digit
Suicide Prevention and Mental Health
crisis hotline the crtc says Canadians
who need urgent help during a mental
health crisis will be able to call or
text 988 free of charge Nationwide
starting in November of 2023. those are
the same three digits adopted by a
similar hotline launched in the United
States last month the announcement comes
more than 19 months after the House of
Commons unanimously voted in favor of
establishing the hotline
the employer Strikes Back ahead what
quiet firing is and why workers need to
watch out
the Bank of Canada could move forward
with another aggressive interest rate
hike next week new data shows the
economy stayed in relatively good shape
during the second quarter of the year
the economy grew at an annual rate of
3.3 percent from April to June now
that's still short of the bank of
Canada's forecast businesses ramped up
their investment in inventory and there
was a spike in household spending on
clothing and Footwear as more people
head back to the office
but not everyone is Keen to part with
their work from home setup some are even
sticking it to employers through the
quiet quitting movement doing your job
to the requirements but nothing above
and beyond well now there's another new
labor Trend emerging and it's called
quiet firing and as Ann gaviola explains
it's gaining momentum
and usually that person doesn't just get
extremely underpaid they're also treated
really badly in the workplace quiet
quitting meet quiet firing which is also
sparking conversations on Tick Tock and
Beyond it's almost like a game of
chicken sometimes for employees and
employers quiet firing involves
withholding promotions and important
work in the hopes of pushing an employee
out no firing involved but it can lead
to legal and financial consequences for
a company that doesn't tread carefully
if you are mistreating an employee and
making their lives miserable within the
workplace you could be held liable for
committing a constructive dismissal
quiet quitting which is just doing your
job and nothing more is a symptom of a
Workforce that feels overworked and
burnt out after the roller coaster of
the last two years some setting clear
boundaries with the lines between work
and home life were blurred Economist
Linda Nazareth warns managers and
employers that quiet firing is a symptom
of something else too honestly if you
are quietly firing people it's either a
bad Management in that you're trying to
not pay them in a layoff or you just
don't want to deal with this head-on and
now employees have little tolerance for
poor leadership with many workplaces
still in flux some bosses are having a
hard time adjusting you have managers
who are being asked to manage hybrid and
remote workforces they weren't trained
to do that and they're also supposed to
engage a Workforce who may be present
maybe somewhere else but who does not
feel that they are particularly happy
with things quiet firing can poison
workplace culture and in this
competitive labor market quiet firing
can mean losing your top talent too and
they're not afraid to call out quiet
firing on the way out after all loud
quitting has never been easier what is
loudly quitting you under packing your
belongings and leaving you don't pay me
my worth someone else will
and gaviola Global News Toronto
remembering Diana next how the Royals
tragic death is still sending shock
waves 25 years later
many people remember where they were 25
years ago today when they heard the news
that Princess Diana had died she was one
of the most famous women of the 20th
century and her tragic death at the age
of 36 sent shockwaves Around the World
Eric Sorensen has more on her life her
Legacy and her lasting impact on the
monarchy
it doesn't seem so long ago for many the
memory of Princess Diana has not faded
the sadness has not eased the day
I'm about it was awful just like
yesterday
the chance you approach you right back
to those days 25 years ago the heartache
was as deep as the ocean of bouquets
outside Kensington Palace
Public's first glimpses
the shy princess to be and I suppose in
love
gross
the wedding of the century
[Music]
and a mother of a future Monarch Diana
was one of the most compelling figures
in the 20th century
so charismatic she out Sean Charles and
the royal family but her husband's
Affairs and then her own brought a very
public and agonizing end to the marriage
did nothing to diminish The public's
fascination with Diana she was glamorous
and a global icon who still captivated
the public with her causes like advocacy
and support of those with HIV AIDS and
her Embrace of those in need of help
and then in an instant
she was gone the public outpouring was
unlike anything we've seen before was
down in the queen of people's house just
look at the evidence the fact that
people mourned her loss probably in some
ways greater than their members of their
own family Diana left her Mark the royal
family was forced to respond to public
scrutiny and in turn learned to reach
out Diana probably challenged the royal
family the way it operates in a way that
no one had ever done before and that no
one not even Harry has been able to do
since Diana's enduring Legacy of course
is her children in Prince Harry her
rebelliousness an outsider in the royal
family I wanted to be a day to share the
spirit of my mum with my family with my
children who I wish could have met her
and William who is to be king is 40 now
he dotes on his children and he has her
natural ease meeting Ordinary People it
was Diana's way of bringing up her boys
that is the influence on the money of
the future in Paris where she died they
recall a generosity of spirit
lady Dai worked for social causes he
says and United all Races I think it's
just someone who needs to be remembered
remembered forever and for other things
she did Diana will be remembered as a
princess with a common touch
Eric Sorensen Global News
it's that last line of the Elton John
song that comes to me your candle burned
out long before your Legend ever did
that's global national for this
Wednesday night I'm Farah Nasser thank
you for spending part of your evening
with us tonight's your Canada is
Kootenai National Park in the
Southeastern British Columbia until
tomorrow take care of yourselves and
each other good night
[Music]